thanks yaser we are here with the
executive director of the grand chess
tour Mr Michael kolarkovski Michael
first of all welcome back to the show
we've been having a lot of fun in this
tournament and I have to say it's been
the Magnus show so far it is indeed in
the indeed Chris actually this is the
last uh tournament in our European tour
and it's very exciting because uh Magnus
yesterday actually demonstrated
phenomenal performance
hard to repeat even by to Marshalls
right but he does exceptionally well as
you could see he didn't do that well in
Rapid the same as in Warsaw in previous
tournament but this time he did a little
bit better because the gap between him
and the leader in Warsaw was much bigger
here it was just a walk in the park for
him would you call it historical nine
out of nine if you count the two rapid
games it's 11 out of 11. yeah
uh yeah I believe you know it is
historical but I believe that even nine
out of nine it's hard to find maybe you
know when Fisher won U.S Championship
with perfect score that's the only
comparison but again it was classical
cheers this is Blitz and bleeds you know
you can have any single error and you
out what is it about the grand Chester
that incentivizes type of performances
we've seen that in the sync field cup as
well with Fabiano now we see it yeah but
Fabiana did seven and all right yeah in
a row and it was also phenomenal and
nobody as of today could repeat right
yes so it's very difficult to win uh in
a row so many games I believe kaspara
won's like five in a row but not seven
or uh not nine right so it is a
phenomenal performance and it's
absolutely stunning to see this an
audience was ecstatic and even Carlson
himself demonstrated how excited he was
he always was dancing he was out of out
of stage he was he was indeed Michael
whenever you come on the show you always
give us good news do you have any good
news for us well you or you know that I
always working hard to bring some uh new
tournaments
for grantchester and right now very
close to get one more European stop in
Western Europe so it's already in works
but it would be teaser so everybody can
wait a little bit but I believe in a
couple of months we will have already
full uh full schedule for grantchester
2024. that's a great teaser and we're
looking forward to hear more about that
we do have a couple more stops let's
actually take a look at those couple of
stuffs coming up as you were mentioning
the European tour is over we're going
straight to St Louis in November very
excited about this one yes yes it would
be very exciting and I'm sure we will
see many interesting games big fights
and
I don't know whether it would be new uh
winner of the grand shoes tour or it
would be a repetition of 2022. we'll see
how Ali Reza will do Michael thank you
very much for joining us thanks for the
news and we'll see you around sure thank
you guys thank you Christian and thank
you